Guys, I have a confession to make.
Guys, you guys, I'm
serious. I
am an addict. I am a fucking dirty
fiend. I would go to judge about that
shit, but I'm never getting fucking clean. I
am addicted, the dirtiest of them all. Like
seriously, bro, it's gonna leave you all appalled.
But I can't hide it anymore. I can't
hide it anymore. No! No! Ahhh!
It's time to come clean. It
isn't lean. It isn't grass. I am
addicted to eating.
Every fucking day. Every fucking day. Every fucking
day. Every fucking day. Gonna be sticky, yeah.
Shit is gross and putty. Every fucking day.
Every fucking day. Gonna be sticky, yeah. Shit
is gross and putty. The stinkier the better,
I swear, boy, I got demons and they
are taking over and I'll never be sober.
I am addicted to lean. I am addicted
to grass. But I'm addicted, I'm addicted, yeah,
I'm addicted to eating. Every fucking day. Every
fucking day. Gonna be sticky, yeah. Shit is
gross and putty. Every fucking day. Every fucking
day. Gonna be sticky, yeah. Shit is gross
and putty. Shit is dripped in dookie. Dirty
sticky coochie. Real nasty poopy. Really fucking poopy.
Ah! Ah! Holy
shit, bro. This song is so fucking shit,
man. Jesus.